[Musique]
serge hoarau maire de petite-île
accueilli cyrille melchior président du
conseil départemental ce mardi 31
juillet dans sa commune ensemble ils ont
signé le pacte de solidarité
territoriale qui apporte à petite-île
1,3 million d'euros sur le volet
investissement et 24000 euros sur le
volet dépenses de fonctionnement la
délégation s'est ensuite rendue sur le
lieu des travaux de confortement des
voiries suite au passage de fakir une
belle illustration de ce que l'on
souhaite faire quand les communaux comme
ça des des aléas faut réparer rapidement
surtout sont des imprévus des hameaux
rêver serge hoarau a ensuite enfilé sa
casquette de vice présidente du
département délégué à l'agriculture mais
également celle de président de la
saphir pour inaugurer de nouveaux
équipements de pré traitement de l'eau
et de pompage pour l'irrigation à saint
pierre cette station de prétraitement va
permettre de limiter le nombre de jours
de fermeture de l'eau pour l'irrigation
ou même pour les fermiers qui achètent
de l'eau avec la saphir vous le savez
nous avons l'obligation de donner de
l'eau à 10 mt eu aux fermiers aux
agriculteurs et lorsque nous avons de la
kabylité importante file à de fortes
pluies dans le bras de la plaine
l'eau arrive ici à haut niveau 2021
donc il nous faut un temps de
prétraitement la station prend de l'eau
à 150 nt eu pour livrer à disons que ça
montre bien que nous allons pouvoir
gérer le temps de fermeture du périmètre
grâce à cet outil il y a un très bel
équipement ce tueur qui a été réalisée
par le département de la réunion financé
par l'union européenne plus de 7
millions de travaux doit amener l'eau
ici cette eau qui s'est bien sûr à
l'agriculture mais pas seulement
l'agriculture qui s'est aussi aux
communes et donc aux familles de
saint-pierre petites îles et des
communes environnantes
je tiens à le dire ici on s'inscrit dans
le développement durable
parce que on amène de l'eau qui s'est
offert mis aux agriculteurs aux
industriels mais on crée aussi de
l'énergie puisque cette énergie elle est
renouvelable
c'est un bel outil de co développement
et de développement
ici que nous avons en fin de matinée
cyrille melchior et serge hoarau ont
rejoint patrick mallet maire de saint
louis pour inaugurer une extension du
périmètre d'irrigation dans les eaux de
bellevue et de maison rouge
un investissement de 9 millions d'euros
qui permet d'irriguer 250 hectares
supplémentaires pour 40 agriculteurs qui
attendait depuis trente ans beaucoup de
richesses en gagnent en banane et en
maraîchage parce que on avait besoin de
louer ici il peut y avoir une période de
mieux travailler c'est de travailler un
peu plus fun mais en n'ayant plus de 2
des cas ce qu'ont fait les voir
l'élevage en même temps et puis même
fait un peu de bouteille maréchal pétain
une journée qui s'est achevée à la
mairie de saint-denis où patrick mallet
maire de la ville a à son tour signé le
pacte de solidarité territoriale
une enveloppe de 3 7 millions d'euros
pour la ville de saint louis
c'est une grande joie si j'ai une
bouffée d'oxygène pour la ville de saint
louis
et en tout cas c'est un
l'aboutissement d'une politique sûr
d'arrêter voulu une nouvelle présidence
département et nous en sommes très
heureux
alors sur le
le pack dessus et d'arrêter territoriale
en investissement ce sont
essentiellement des travaux routiers
pouvoir réparer les dégâts du cyclone
birgitta du masi et fakir et des travaux
dans les écoles
quand je vois que le maire de saint lui
me dis que je veux utiliser les crises
du département fois améliorée restauré
et réaménagé les chemins endommagés là
je ne peux que l'accompagner dans ses
efforts et c'est là tout l'esprit du
pacte de solidarité départementale c'est
l'accompagnement avec efficacité dans un
souci de rapidité
l'accompagnement des communes dans la
réhabilitation de leurs équipements de
proximité hui signature de pactes de
solidarité territoriale ont déjà été
réalisés mais dispositif des deux
communes est doté d'une enveloppe
globale de 90 millions d'euros
[Musique]